Yeah,
are you talking about it is informed
risk taking an informed risk taking in
that culture is fundamental towards
supporting innovation.
Number two,
they've got to be an educated
population,
uh,
if,
if you're working on something that you
don't quite understand the probability
of making it better by messing with it,
just reduced.
So if just think about those two tenants
for awhile,
a culture that supports it,
and then number two,
then,
uh,
enough,
enough education and knowledge and
teamwork to be able to go to go build
it,
that there are very few individuals
anymore they can understand one of our
products and some of them have over a
billion transistors.
It's hard to know what each one of them
does,
right?
So there are teams of people that create
these and they're bigger teams of people
that try to validate them and distribute
them,
et cetera.
So if I was thinking about a third
thing,
it would be about building that culture
of teamwork and allowing teams then
being innovative
at the Intel fellow level,
the top,
the very top approximately hundred
scientists and technologists that we
have,
we tell them they can have half the time
to themselves and they can go work in
that.
Very few of them actually take us up on
But the offer is genuine now it means in
some,
in some area that they have some
expertise,
right?
Um,
we actually haven't really faced a lot
of that difficulty because because our
products are so incredibly complex,
beautifully complex,
one could argue and because there's so
much change that goes on all the time.
So if you're interested in the field of
computing,
working for Intel is just our great
place to be.
Right.
And they have a tendency to work in,
to work in work in that area.
Now we,
we try to go off and then there was a
pretty formal process for determining in
the R and d labs what technology's still
hold promise and when to kind of reduce
the funding in an area.
And when and when to move it forward.
So we have a lot of process until it's a
process driven company.
We have a lot of processes that do that,
but fundamentally the idea is that you
can do most of the development in the
area of expertise,
some form of computing.
And then in the research labs
themselves,
a very organized process to determine
which ones we continue to find out which
ones we,
uh,
we pass on.
Well,
there's the culture.
The first one I answered the tenants of
the culture would be first you have to
respect that.
And that means doesn't always work.
The second one is education.
Talked about that.
See if there's a third one.
Oh,
well,
I think the third one is really you have
to just feel inwardly wonderful about
the success.
So if you step back and say,
okay,
you're allowed to fail,
and then people are educated,
then do you really celebrate those
people that can move it forward.
And sometimes a team moves it forward
and then sometimes you know,
just one person makes a difference.
And we give away the intel achievement
awards every year and lots of times
those are teams of people where,
you know,
our team has done something really
innovative and you have a little bit of
money,
but we give them a great party,
uh,
that every once in a while it was just
one individual who stands up and it's so
clear at the corporate level that that
one person moved intel and those are
really special.
We,
we,
we do throw the party,
but it's not that much of it.
Um,
let's step back and say what innovation
really is.
Innovation is the ability to build a new
product or new service in some way that
that betters the product line or
hopefully is solving a customer need
better than before.
So we reward that.
First of all,
this is a,
be careful what you ask for.
You know,
really good design engineers have a
tendency to then become group leads and
they can certainly move up that
engineering chain.
We allow,
we allow scientists and engineers to
either move up into a management change
or stay on their technical leadership
towards an Intel fellow.
And an Intel fellow board until senior
fellow is the same,
you know,
range in the company,
same grade,
same salary if not more than vice
presidents.
So there is,
you know,
we,
we kind of put our money where I'm out
there and we recruit,
retain and we award those people that
can move this technology forward in,
in,
in a meaningful way.
And then the second thing,
which I keep trying to say what really
makes it work,
you've got people around you that shared
this culture that want to be doing it
too,
that when you know,
when you call them up at at night and
you say,
yeah,
I know it's after work,
but I just got to talk to you about
this.
I'm so excited and they don't hang up on
you.
So I think it's that combination of
respecting the individual and in dealing
with all the management structures and
changes and challenges that result by
then second of all,
having a culture and being able to
recruit other people into the
organization that share that common goal
set.
There are a lot of people that would say
that we have lost some of that edge and
some would argue with that vehemently.
So let me just point out the data,
right?
The data are that,
that we're no longer producing the most
engineers.
We are no longer producing the most
amount of,
uh,
the most amount of,
of,
uh,
of new new companies.
We have been the technological lead in
the world.
We really had technical supremacy for
decades and are higher our lead,
our higher education institutions still
have that.
We have the best higher education system
in the world,
but if we really want to remain a
technological powerhouse in the next 30
years,
we need to start internalizing though
all those scores that are coming out to
explain that we're in the twenties in
math and science.
Our children are not as well educated.
They don't have the same work ethic
whether we like it or not.
That's what the test indicate.
And I think we have to look at the
systemic issues that are causing that
and go after it.
Enjoying them.
If you,
if you step back and you say,
uh,
there's a creative,
people will always give you the,
you will spend most of your time on
creative people and,
and that means that they will be the
people that you,
you,
you know,
you want to most embraced.
Sometimes you're just most want to argue
with the others because it depends on
where they're going at any given at any
given moment,
but most will usually have to enjoy and
respect their creativity.
If,
if creative people believe they are
liked and respected,
then they will continue to be more and
more creative.
And I don't,
I don't necessarily relate creativity
with,
with lack of discipline.
You can be very creative within a
discipline.
So if we're talking about how do you
deal with undisciplined creative people
than I think,
then I think that's just a matter of
trying to establish a common goal.